اول مره وسيله اعلاميه ستدخل الى هذا
الجزء من مطار مروي العسكري
ستتابعون الان هذه الصور لحجم الضرر الذي
لحق بالمطار
الاليات العسكريه في هذا المكان حجم
الدمار كما تتابعون دمار كامل حريق كامل
لهذه الاليات
احترقت بكاملها نتيجه للاشتباكات
والعمليات
المسلحه
ونذكر ونشير ايضا بان سلاح المهندسين
التابع للقوات المسلحه السودانيه الان
ينتشر في محيط مروي
وداخل القاعده ليمشط وليتعامل مع الاجسام
الغير منفجره التي ايضا ربما تشكل عبئا
ثقيلا على بقيه القوات الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه وتشكل ايضا خطوره على المواطنين
في المناطق المحيطه بمطار مروي الدولي
والعسكري التحرك في هذه النقطه هو التحرك
بحذر لا يمكن ان نتعمق اكثر من واقع محمد
هنا بعض
الاجسام التي ما زالت مشتعله
تلاحظون الان هذا الدخان
هذه الاليه
هذه الاليه الان ما زالت النار مشتعله في
هذا الجزء من المطار يبدو انها نتيجه لاخر
الضربات عسكريه كانت هنا في هذه المنطقه
هذا هو الوضع للاليات المحترقه اليات
مدنيه وسيارات تتبع لمطار مروي الدولي
وللقاعده الجويه العسكريه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات